but first up he is the former governor
of Arkansas the author of God Guns grits
and gravy also I believe he won eight
states in 2008 in the Republican primary
Mike Huckabee's over here how are you
governor hey Bill how you doing see you
thank you for being here my pleasure
I know you're concerned about bad
language I tried to clean that up good
and I I I'm telling you that could have
been worse it usually is yes and you
know what I I agree with you sometimes I
and that's watch a sitcom at eight
o'clock at night and it's like at eight
o'clock at night it's like five minutes
in and it's three dick Joe enough easy
sorry I you know what I'm saying yes uh
unfortunately I do yes
so but you know I read in your book you
said that you know you grew up in the
south and and there was a certain
decorum there men did not cuss in front
of women typically that was the case
there was certain sort of just unwritten
code that people behaved with a level of
respect for others and and but they had
slaves look I'm not a pet not in my life
no not in your lifetime but I just mean
like
I'm just saying
you're saying cry of the priorities you
know I would rather hug people who
didn't have slaves and cussed yeah but
you know what what I think people had a
sense of respect for other people I'm
not a prude I hear language all the time
that I find that it's not the things I
would say right I hear it that's okay
but here's what I feel like when we
become coarse the coarseness of our
language ends up becoming the attitude
we have toward other people I agree and
there's a social maydel they become very
just mean and angry you on Twitter I am
yeah nasty it is very read your feed
they must say terrible things they say
awful things they say other things about
everybody but you know free speech is a
great thing but responsible speeches are
part of the balance of that and I never
want the government I wouldn't even want
anyone else okay
shutting me down or shutting you down or
anyone else but I'd like for people to
self-police and to say you know I can
say anything I want but I'm going to say
the things that are more wholesome that
are more edifying to the overall culture
and society that make us a more civil
country rather than a less civil country
okay let's talk about your book now I
remember you're on when you had your
your previous book which was about I
mean you used to be chris Christie level
right I did I'd write a new boy you were
a big boy and and you lost a lot of
weight I mean you're not a rail but you
look healthy all right neither am i well
you know I went through a process on
today you look healthier than people who
do get skinny at your age well thank you
look healthy at my age which is my age I
mean I lost 100 pounds back in 2003 if I
didn't I think the doctor was quite
right in saying you know I'd be entering
the last decade in my life so clearly
I've outlived that you know I've had
bouts with weight gain but I really
believe that one of the most important
things that we have to do is to take
care of ourselves and and that's again
it's a matter of personal responsibility
okay and I think that's right your new
book is called God Guns grits and gravy
yes in the South sounds like you
flip-flopped on raving
you got to understand in the south gravy
is a beverage right I know bear aren't
you off the gravy I mean it yeah let me
know the term God Guns grits and gravy
is not a southern recipe book right it's
really a depiction of the fact that
there are bubbles of influence in places
like New York Washington and Hollywood
and then there is a whole bunch of
America in the Middle often called
flyover country but my term for it over
the past few years I said when people
would ask me where I live and say I live
in the land of God Guns grits and gravy
and by that I mean it's a place if
somebody comes up to you and says you
know I heard your mother is sick and in
the hospital I'm praying for her
nobody's creeped out by that or if
someone says heard you just got a new
Weatherby 300 say that everywhere you
don't think people pray in California
if I lived in California I'd be praying
alone is a weird thing be good because I
hear this all the time young social
conservatives like yourself you feel put
upon you feel like somehow the world is
against you you're 80% of the country
you have the vast majority even in the
blue states most people are religious
most liberals are still follow a
religion most Democrats do I'm the only
one staring at you
nobody else is so I don't I don't I
don't understand that persecution
complex except it's in Christian history
you love being persecuted no I think
that there is if you look at television
shows and movies you'll be hard-pressed
to find a sitcom in which Christians
which do represent a significant part of
the population significant vast majority
won't see them presented as normal
decent people they're usually a
charlatan
they're often why depend yes bill
Christians are depicted as Charlotte
you're thinking of Jews no
IIIi don't know where you're getting
that term but but I have to tell you
something good this may blow your mind I
made a little list of places I've
traveled okay cuz I just end up almost
every weekend I could longer list but I
just picked out and see if you can tell
why I picked these cities this place
I've been in the last two years
Huntsville Alabama Nashville Tennessee
let's not do this for everyone
Memphis Baton Rouge Savannah Topeka
Kansas Oklahoma City Little Rock Mobile
Alabama Birmingham Alabama
Kansas City Charleston West Virginia Des
Moines Cedar Rapids Macon Georgia what
do they all have in common they probably
loved you they ballin snakes that you
won in 2008 wonderful people they are
smart people they are brilliant people
but I see I you have this thing in your
book Bubba Ville you were just
describing it and I think I know Bubba
Ville better than you too well I think
I'm in more cities than you are and I
see in America I don't they I don't know
if you know this America I don't know if
you know how actually people in the
cities yes I'm sure if you go out in the
deliverance area get there
but they look act and laughed just like
people everywhere else this country is
not Bubba Ville anymore no but bill I
think what I would say to you there's a
lot of people who'll come to your show
whether it's in whatever city there are
certainly there are liberals and there
are all kinds of people in every city in
America there are conservatives there
are very strict fundamentalist
Christians in Manhattan I understand all
that
I'm saying the prevailing world view and
this is from going to New York every
week for six and a half years I told
people this you can do your show yeah
right and ask me who did I live there I
said no I'm not going to go there unless
they let me duck hunt in Central Park
which I'm pretty sure that's never going
to happen and my point being big why do
you want to kill ducks really they taste
good till you've killed things to eat
them
okay all right what is there is a
difference in the culture in those areas
that really set the table for American
culture and so much of the land that we
call flyover world okay well I'm gonna
ask the panel about this in a minute
okay did this strategy because Ted Cruz
who declared this week is trying to
steal your lunch I mean you're the real
pastor you're a real pastor right it was
25 years okay good we were doing 25
years I know but you are a Jesus
enthusiast I do you do love Jesus I
don't get I don't deny that right in a
way that he really can't compete with
and yet he declared he could have picked
his alma mater Harvard to declare but
that would send an awful message that he
believes in reason and logic uh he
declared at Liberty he's going he's
going after your vote and now I assume
you're running for president you're here
I will make a decision final something
you're running for president okay so
I mean no I mean winning eight states
the last time you ran that that's a lot
of states I mean a lot of people run and
don't win any state yeah
so you have a place to to a springboard
to go from what do you think about Ted
Cruz getting in is he a threat to you
well everybody's a threat to me I think
they should all back and they'll let you
have it to myself you know there's
everybody assumes that the only people
who supported me eight years ago with
the people who were religious and the
fact is if they'd all really supported
me I'd have been the nominee right the
fact is a lot of the people who
supported me were working-class people
the kind of people I grew up with
because that's where I came from I am
NOT blueblood
I'm blue-collar right I'm the first male
in my entire family lineage that ever
graduated high surf in the same town as
Bill Clinton I am you know Bill Clinton
and I both from hope Arkansas you could
have flipped a coin and wound up in
different parties could have but he
moved away when he was like 5 years old
and I stayed my family didn't have
enough money to go so there we were he
moved away from a lot of things that
working-class people that's where that's
where my support really came from it was
from truck drivers and baggage handlers
and taxi drivers and there's a loss of
connection between the political class I
Whittle or I wish we had more time but
we to talk about why I don't think
people like that should vote Republican
but you make that case and we'll see if
they do I think I can Thank You governor
I appreciate your your great to come
here thank you
Thank You Governor Mike Huckabee
you